well the weird are getting weirder the
Donald Trump said in Scotland that he
was leaving early in order to go to the
E Gene Carroll rape trial in New York
apparently to testify which was news to
so many people wow Trump's leaving he's
going to testify and then he just didn't
then his lawyer said he's not testifying
what are you talking about this just
goes from the comical to the completely
absurd to the pathetic and dishonest
here is Donald Trump trump had until
five o'clock P.M yesterday to let the
court know in writing if he was going to
testify today and he told I believe this
was Irish press I don't know if this
video was filmed in Ireland or in
Scotland here is Trump saying how
terrible it is he's got to leave early
he could be playing golf you know he's
got to leave early and go testify I
guess in the rape trial that's happening
in New York take a look at this
oh boy
our video is glitching badly that's not
good let's let's take a here we go leave
Ireland and I have to leave Scott
trial Mr President
it's a disgrace that it's allowed to
happen it's by false accusations against
a rich guy
or in my case against
a famous rich and political person
that's leading the polls by 40 points
right and I have to go back for a woman
that made a false accusation about me
and I have a judge who's extremely
hostile and I'm going to go back and I'm
going to confront this with this woman
is a disgrace and it shouldn't be
allowed to happen in our country all
right so he very clearly says I'm gonna
go back and I'm gonna confront the woman
and I'm gonna go to the trial okay well
he had up until yesterday at five
o'clock to notify the court that he's
going to do that and of course he's not
going to NBC News Trump won't testify in
E Gene Carroll rape and defamation trial
after judges deadline passes judge Lewis
Kaplan set a deadline of 5 PM Sunday for
Trump to notify the court if he wanted
to testify after his lawyer said that he
would not
so what do we make of it we don't know
did Trump think he was going to go
testify did Trump think the media would
be impressed by him saying he was going
to go his attorneys did not issue a
filing by the 5 PM Sunday deadline that
was set
closing arguments started earlier this
morning lawyers for Trump and Carol
rested their case in the Civil Trial
last week Kaplan left open the
possibility for Trump who said he would
not appear to take the witness stand
giving him time to change his mind
Trump's lawyer said last week Trump will
not testify they are not putting on any
Witnesses uh attorney Joe takapina
reiterated that on Thursday when he
rested he told the judge he spoke to
Trump earlier and Trump waived his right
to testify Trump however told reporters
on a golf course in Ireland he was going
back to New York because of the case
I'll probably attend she's a fake it's a
disgrace I've got to go back and do it
so listen I have absolutely no idea
where this case is going to go we're
going to look at
um deposition testimony from Trump in a
in a couple of minutes I have no idea
what this court will find on any of
these questions it has been
obfuscation and chaos and wacky
depositions it's it's been there's no
sensible way
for me to come up with a prediction and
we'll kind of have our answers soon so
so we'll we'll figure that out even
legal opinions that I've looked at are
sort of split as to what is to be
expected here uh what we can be sure of
what we can be sure of is that no matter
the outcome Trump will claim either
Victory or will martyr himself that no
matter what that we know is going to
happen why did Trump say he was going to
testify when he wasn't we don't know
let's now look at what when Trump did
testify in the sense of being deposed
insane videos released over the weekend
we've talked on the show about how
internet service providers have been
logging everything their customers do
online and selling that data tech
companies use trackers in websites and
apps to collect your data you can Shield
yourself from all of it by using a VPN
every time you connect to the internet
the VPN I use is private internet access
it's the only VPN that has proven
multiple times in court they do not log
your activity our sponsor private
internet access hides my IP address
prevents big Tech from being able to
paint a picture of who I am and what I
do online and it works for all of your
favorite streaming platforms like
Netflix and Hulu to access shows and
movies normally only available in other
countries it's one of the only vpns that
works for peer-to-peer file sharing and
the best part is you can protect
unlimited devices with just one account
going online without private internet
access is like leaving your phone
unattended in a crowded room anyone can
just take a glance my audience gets 83
percent off that's just 203 a month plus
four extra months for free go to
piavpn.com Pacman the link is down below